It's always the analog things,
like projectors, that cause
problems for things like this.
Well, thank you very
much for coming.
My name's Greg DeMichillie.
I'm the director of product
management for the Cloud
Platform at Google.
That means I lead the team of
product managers responsible
for things like App Engine and
Compute Engine, the developer
experience, our developer tools,
the billing system, and
basically anything that you
touch as an end user developer
coming to the Google Cloud.
Because of the way we work at
Google, I'm also responsible
for the product management
teams that build the
fundamental infrastructure that
Google itself runs on.
So if you think about what we
do, we allow you to build on
the same infrastructure that
we use ourselves at Google.
And our team of product managers
is responsible for
both the internal and external
facing parts of that.
I've got a background
in developer tools.
I was at Microsoft for
10 years in the '90s.
And so I've been building
things for
developers my whole career.
And I'm really happy to be here
in Telaviv where there's
such a vibrant community of
start-ups and ISVs and IT.
I've only been here so far
one day, and this is my
first trip to Israel.
But it's really exciting to be
here, so thank you for coming.
I thought today I'd start at a
high level and then go down
into giving you an overview
of what the Cloud Platform
actually has to offer.
First of all, if you think about
what's happening in the
way we build applications today,
there's a number of
things that have fundamentally
changed the way we build
applications.
The first is this almost
limitless capacity that we
have available, and not just
available, but cheaply.
A statistic I saw the other day
said for about $600 you
can buy enough disk storage to
store all the world's music.
That's phenomenal if
you think about it.
You think about a time not that
long ago when, to build
an application, you had
to buy hardware.
You had to buy storage.
You had to buy networking.
Before your first customer even
came to your website, you
had thousands and thousands
of dollars that you
had to put up front.
Now, with the way that the cloud
is developing, you don't
have to do that.
You really have limitless
capacity available on demand
when you need it in
a real time way.
And if you think about the way
applications tend to work,
they tend to fall into
a couple patterns.
The first kind of application
pattern you see a lot is the
classic batch computing.
Every night at 2AM, my system
runs a report from all of
yesterday's sales.
And at 4AM it's done.
And then it sits idle for
the next 22 hours.
And in that model, you buy a
computer and you pay for it 24
hours a day even though it
actually is only running a
task for two hours overnight.
And so you have wasted money.
Another pattern you see is
the hyper growth company.
You're in a startup, and you're
doubling every week the
number of users you have.
And now you're faced with the
task of-- can I even by
computers fast enough?
Can I go online and order
hardware and get it installed
fast enough to keep up?
And the answer is
no, you can't.
So you're immediately faced with
the choice of buying too
much to satisfy your growth,
or having unsatisfied
customers because you can't
keep up with the growth of
your company.
We see the unpredictable
bursting.
My application is running
fine and I'm serving
my customer's needs.
And then I end up being on
the front page of Reddit.
Or I get picked up
by a blogger.
And all of a sudden, out of the
blue, my network traffic
goes up 10, 20, 50 times.
What do I do?
As a business, I can't afford
to provision enough capacity
just in case I get massively
popular.
So I end up again having
unsatisfied customers because
I couldn't meet up
with demand.
And the fourth pattern you see a
lot is predictable bursting.
Think of FIFA.
Very predictably, every four
years the World Cup happens
and there's a huge uptake
in their traffic
load that they have.
And very predictably, once
the World Cup's over, it
settles back down.
So what do they do?
Do they buy enough capacity to
handle that peak when they
know it's coming, even though
it's going to be wasted?
Or do they again have this risk
of potentially having
unsatisfied customers because
they couldn't meet the demand?
All of these speak to the need
to move away from the model of
owning your own hardware,
provisioning your own
hardware, and onto a model
where you can provision
hardware on the fly.
And your application can use as
much compute resources as
it needs, but only the resources
that it needs.
So how does that relate
to Google?
Well, it turns out Google has
been facing this exact problem
for 14 years.
From the moment we built Google
Search, we had the
problems of-- how do you deal
with going from thousands of
users to millions or
billions of users?
How do you provision capacity so
that you're not wasting it?
How do you get power
efficiency?
And along the way, we've had to
invent a number of hardware
and software techniques just
to make Google work.
If you think about it, when we
set out to build a search
engine for the internet, the
first thing you realize is you
need to store multiple copies
of the entire worldwide web.
How do you do that?
There's no file system out there
when we started that
could hold three, four,
five copies of the
entire worldwide web.
So we had to invent that.
There were no storage systems we
could go buy off the shelf
that would satisfy that.
So we had to invent storage
technologies.
And time and time again, as
we've built things like Search
and Apps and Gmail, we've had
to build out the fundamental
hardware and software
infrastructure.
And what we're doing with the
Cloud Platform is we're taking
all of that infrastructure that
we had to build for Apps,
and Search, and Gmail, and Maps,
and Android, and Docs.
And we're now opening it up so
that your applications can run
on that same infrastructure.
These are some photos
of some of the data
centers that we have.
And frankly they're as
pretty to look at as
they are to run on.
I think this one is in Finland,
I'm not certain.
And it's not just the
infrastructure of servers and
storage, it's also networking.
One of the things you may not
know is that last year Google,
in partnership with a couple
other companies, we ran our
own cable underneath the Pacific
Ocean to connect the
US to Asia Pacific.
In fact, we're the
only non-telco--
non telecommunications
company--
that owns its own submarine
cable under the ocean.
And we do that because we
needed high capacity
networking for our data centers
in the US to our data
centers in Asia Pacific.
And this picture here--
see in the middle-- actually
you can't quite see it, is
actually the cable being
laid at the bottom
of the Pacific Ocean.
The trench being laid, the
optic cable being run.
Those are the kind of
investments that we're doing
in our infrastructure in
order to keep pace
with what we need.
And we're inviting you
along for the ride.
It doesn't stop there.
Last year we announced publicly
that we're spending
2.9 billion US in additional
infrastructure.
Data centers, more computers,
more storage, networking
capacity, power efficiency.
And this is going to continue.
And we really don't see a
slowing down in this.
But it's not just hardware.
It's also about software.
I alluded to this earlier when I
talked about Search, and the
fact we had to invent
our own file system.
That has shown up time
and time again.
In 2004, we released
a public paper on a
technology called MapReduce.
You now know that as the
foundation of Hadoop, right?
Internally, we've actually
already moved off MapReduce
and we're on to the
next generation,
something we call Flume.
And that's the technology we're
using to do our own
MapReduce like workloads
at Google.
Similarly, we've made
investments in software like
BigTable, which is a storage
technology that allows you to
do NoSQL-like data storage
with incredibly high
reliability.
And again, we've published
a paper on that.
And that is the foundation of
what you see in the Cloud
Datastore that we'll
talk about.
Dremel, a technology to allow
you to do querying of
non-relational data with the
SQL-like language interface.
Spanner, Colossus, these are
all places where we've
advanced the state of computer
science, we've published
papers, and we're building now
our Cloud Platform products on
top of those.
So that as we continue to invest
in the software to run
our own business, we're exposing
those to you as
developers and you'll see that
as we go through the actual
components of the
Cloud Platform.
And in fact, it's just us when
we've invited other people to
come look at our product.
Wired--
we gave Wired a tour of some of
our data centers and they
really came away with it's not
just about software and
hardware, it's the combination
of software, hardware, and our
efficiency that allows us to
actually run and deploy that
hardware and software.
That's another favorite pictures
of mine of one of our
data centers.
It's interesting, the people
ask the color of the pipes,
did we just paint those?
Because they're the
Google colors.
It turns out it's not true.
There's a standard color coding
in data centers of red,
blue, yellow, and green.
Meaning things like
hot air, cool air,
hot water, cool water.
And it turns out that the
standard is pretty much the
same as the Google colors.
But everybody else just paints
or puts a little
stripe around the pipe.
And so we thought,
why not paint the
whole pipe that color?
Just because we think
it looks better.
And if you're going to work in
one of our data centers, why
shouldn't you work in a
nice environment too?
With that, as background, let
me take you through an
overview of the Cloud Platform
itself that we offer to you as
developers.
First thing is it is a platform
aimed at application
and IT developers.
Google also has software
as a service product,
like Gmail a Docs.
I'm not going to talk
about those today.
They're fabulous products, we
use them ourselves constantly.
We're going to talk today
about infrastructure and
platform as a service in the
form of Compute Engine, App
Engine, and the associated
products.
So first, just make sure we're
level set about the
differences between those
different components.
Basically, when you look at the
Cloud Platform, you can
choose how much control you want
to maintain and how much
automation you want us
to provide for you.
Starting with infrastructure as
a service, at that level,
we will manage for you your
networking, your storage, your
servers, and your
virtualization.
You still have complete
flexibility and control over
what operating system you run,
what middleware you run, what
applications you deploy.
If you go to Platform as a
service, you give up a little
bit of that direct control in
that we now manage your
operating systems and middleware
and run time.
But in exchange for that, you
get much higher levels of
productivity because we can
provide auto scaling, auto
load balancing--
we can provide more of that
for you automatically.
Think about this as the
equivalent of programming in a
high level language
and programming
in a low level language.
Some things you write in C
because you have total
control, and it lets you
do everything you want.
But if you write things in C,
you have to worry about more
of that yourself.
If you write in a language like
Java, you don't think
about [INAUDIBLE] management
anymore.
It's provided automatically.
But you give up a little bit
in terms of flexibility.
We support whatever place you
want to be on this continuum,
from you manage it yourself to
we manage it automatically.
Let's look at specifically
what makes
up the Cloud Platform.
Think of it in three
broad buckets.
First is Compute.
This is the actual application
logic of the system you're
developing, the actual
Compute Services.
Of course, you can't have an
application if you don't also
have storage.
And we have a range of storage
products from traditional SQL
in a cloud hosted environment,
to no SQL, to file system like
storage as well.
And then finally, there's a set
of application services
that you want to use
regardless of what
technologies you're using.
Around things like querying of
data, integrating with Mobile
back-ends caching, queues,
things like that.
And we're going to walk through
each of these in turn.
But it's important to point out
that this is a snapshot in
time and we're evolving
very quickly.
In fact, in the last 12 months,
we've rolled out 163
new features or major
improvements
in the Cloud Platform.
Everything from new instance
types in our virtual machines,
to new programming languages in
App Engine, to new pricing,
new charging, lower prices.
What I'm presenting to you is
a snapshot in time, but we
continue to roll out
new features on
a very rapid basis.
And in fact, we actually
see this accelerating.
Not just holding still,
but getting faster.
As we hire more people, as we
invest more, we find that
we're actually able to increase
the velocity at which
we roll out new features.
Let's take a look inside each of
the parts of the platform.
We'll start with the
Compute side.
Again, this is where the bulk
of your application logic
sits, the actual core of what
your application does.
And we provide two different
models here.
One is infrastructure as a
service in Compute Engine,
where you specify virtual
machines and you
have complete control.
And App Engine, which is highly
managed environment.
Let's start with
Compute Engine.
The main value of Compute Engine
is it's a familiar
environment.
If you're running a Debian
operating system on premises,
on a machine under your desk,
you can very quickly spin up a
virtual machine that runs that
same operating system.
Install the same software,
manage it with the same tools,
run the same applications.
But what you get with running
it on Google is you get the
Google network, for one.
Google has a very, very high
performance network.
You also get very, very
fast start up times.
We have virtual machines
that launch--
from the time you provision the
machine until they're up
and running in about the
10 second range.
And frankly, we think that's
a little slow.
We believe we have room
to lower that further.
And if you think about that,
that again-- that changes how
you think about application
development.
If you could spin up a new
instance of part of your
application in seconds, it
changes the way you think
about application development.
Particularly when you add in
some of the other capabilities
I'm going to talk about.
In addition, of course, we have
persistent disk that you
could store to 10 terabytes
of persistent
disk per virtual machine.
There's a wide range
of operating system
and instance types.
Everything from a fraction of
a core if you're running--
I think we have 1/5 of core-- so
if you're running very like
workloads that you only need
to run to short periods of
time, all the way up to eight
and 16 core machines with a
lot of memory.
One of the features we announced
at I/O that I think
is pretty exciting is really
related to billing.
And I know billing
sounds boring.
How could there be anything
interesting about billing?
But bear with me.
If you think about the way
most cloud providers work
today, you fire up a
virtual machine.
It runs, and even if you run
it for 20 minutes you get
billed for an hour.
So if you run for 61 minutes,
you're billed for two hours.
What we've introduced
is we actually now
have per minute billing.
So you actually only pay for the
specific number of minutes
that your virtual machine
is running.
If you take that combined with
the fact that you can start a
machine up in a few 10s of
seconds or 10 seconds, you
literally can start to throw
cores at a problem.
Because you can economically
afford to spin up 1,000 cores
for 10 minutes, for
20 minutes.
In most cloud providers, if
you spin up 1,000 cores,
you're going to spend a full
hour minimum cost.
Think about the way develop
applications.
And think about places where you
could use a lot of compute
capacity for a very short
period of time.
We're actually now allowing you
to do that economically.
I talked about the
persistent disks.
You can have up to 10 terabytes
of persistent disk
that's attached to your VM's.
We also allow you to have
multiple VM's attached to the
same persistent disk.
Which, again, is a very
convenient way for you share
information between instances.
We have over 64 different
instance types with operating
system support ranging from
CentOS and Debian.
We have things ranging from
fraction of a core up to one,
two, four, eight
core machines.
You can choose whether you want
a local disk attached to
your device, or you don't
want a local disk.
You can save money if you don't
actually require a local
disk running on your
virtual machine.
And we are rolling out
all the additional
features that you expect.
Things like load balancing, we
now have in preview so that
you can attach a cloud hosted
load balancer in
front of your systems.
And over the next year you'll
see us roll out more
capabilities here.
You'll see us add more operating
system support to
our platform.
You'll see us add not just level
three, but level seven
load balancing.
Auto scaling, all sorts of
capabilities will either soon
be in a Trusted Tester or we've
already demoed them at
I/O.
That's the do-it-yourself
model of just give me a
virtual machine.
Is it's familiar, it's
what I know, it's a
low barrier to entry.
But if you do that, you're still
managing things like how
you do auto scaling.
You're still configuring
your operating systems.
You're still patching you're
operating systems.
If you have a software problem,
it's your engineers
who are debugging your
software problem.
App Engine is a platform
as a service.
With App Engine, it's a fully
managed platform.
We wear the pagers, so if
there's something that goes
wrong in the system it's Peter
and his engineers who get the
2AM phone call, not you.
It is a very easy development
model.
You just upload your code, and
then we actually deploy it out
to the application.
And it really allows you to
focus on the parts that make
your application unique.
If you think about it as the
developer, the mega trend over
the last 20 years for developers
is you want to
spend more time writing code
that makes your app different.
Not boilerplate code that's
the same in every single
application.
App Engine is the next
step in that process.
App Engine automatically scales
both the front ends and
the back ends of your
application.
And, in fact, if you are having
no traffic, we scale
you down to zero and
you pay nothing.
And again, that's the sort of
thing you can get with a fully
managed platform like
App Engine.
In terms of features, we
support the popular
programming .
Languages for quite a while
we've supported Java and
Python and Go.
We've just now rolled out--
we announced at I/O--
support for PHP.
So if you're a PHP developer,
you can now bring your PHP
code and run it on App Engine.
We provide a variety
of storage options.
And I'll talk more about storage
a little later, but
both SQL and NoSQL storage
you can access.
There's a variety of services.
If you want Memcache to make
your application faster with
App Engine, you don't have to
go and configure a Memcache.
You going in the console, you
check a box that's saying I
want Memcache.
How much storage do I want?
If you want, you can get shared
Memcache so your memory
cache is shared among
applications.
If you want to pay a little
bit more, you could have
dedicated Memcache that's for
the exclusive use of your
application.
And you could specify exactly
how much cache you want.
We provision it, we manage it
for you, all automatically.
Also, all the typical things
you would expect.
There are local development
tools so that you can run your
code locally on your laptop to
test out your application,
make sure it works.
With one command line,
upload the code and
you're up and running.
Peter's going to talk a lot more
about App Engine, I think
specifically on PHP
and some of these
things in a little bit.
So I'm not going to spend too
much time on App Engine
specifically.
That's the compute side.
Now you've got your application
[INAUDIBLE]
and hosted.
What about storage?
Well, storage comes in a
couple different forms.
The first is cloud storage.
Cloud storage is your hard
drive in the sky.
You just have a bucket you write
to, you just give us a
blob of data.
We store it and you
can retrieve it.
Think about it logically as
the equivalent of Google
Drive, in that your application
has its own-- your
project has its own
storage place.
You write things into folders,
you retrieve them.
We also have two types of
application data storage.
There's Cloud SQL, which is a
cloud hosted version of MySQL.
So all the things you're
familiar with with MySQL apply
a Cloud SQL.
And we also Cloud Datastore,
which is a NoSQL key value
pair system.
And I'll talk specifically
about what that means.
And finally, we have persistent
disks, which I
alluded to.
Which are those virtual hardware
disks that can be
attached to virtual machines
inside a Compute Engine.
Let's talk about these
one at a time.
NoSQL, key value pairs,
SQL storage--
so traditional [? scheme ?]
environment--
blob store--
in terms of cloud storage--
and then block store.
So let's take them one by one.
Cloud storage.
This is the analogous
to Google Drive.
It is high performance.
You have very large
storage capacity.
If you are familiar with Amazon
S3, we actually have an
S3 compatible interface.
If you're currently using
Amazon, it's actually very
easy for you to start using
Cloud Storage either as a
redundant version or if you want
to migrate away from S3
on to Cloud Storage we make
that very simple to do.
The key value here is that we
provide Google networking,
Google network performance,
extremely high durability, low
cost, and an SLA associated
with it.
Datastore is a particularly
interesting one.
This is the key value
NoSQL storage.
And again, if you think back
to when I talked about
building what we needed to build
for Google, that one of
the first things we realized
again when we were building
Search was there was no existing
NoSQL store that was
close to providing the
reliability and the
performance that we
needed for Search.
So we had to build our own, and
what we built is in fact
the underpinnings
of Datastore.
Accessible anywhere.
This is the same--
what we've done is we've taken
this high replication
Datastore that used to be just
part of App Engine, and we've
made it available to any
application anywhere.
So Cloud Datastore can be
accessed from Compute Engine,
from App Engine, actually
even from Amazon--
if you have applications hosted
there, you can access
the Cloud Datastore.
One of the really interesting
qualities this has is when you
query the Datastore, the speed
doesn't depend on the size of
the data set.
If you have a one megabyte data
set, a query will take
the same amount of time for one
terabyte data set as a one
megabyte data set.
So if you think about that, that
also changes the way you
think about application.
We automatically replicate
your data across
multiple data centers--
as many as five--
which means you have very high
reliability, even in the event
of natural disasters
or power outages.
We are able to deliver
reliability that's far beyond
what you would get from--
certainly from
any on premise system--
but even from most
cloud providers.
The statistic I find
shocking--
or pleasantly surprised in--
Datastore is currently serving
over 4.5 trillion
requests per month.
Not billion, even.
Trillion.
This is a very reliable, very
high uptime service.
And it's the core of our
NoSQL offerings.
It automatically scales, again,
so you don't have to
provision it.
It's a schemaless system, so
if you are adding data you
just simply add new data.
You don't ever have
to do a SQL--
a schema-like update.
It's available through both a
RESTful interface and directly
from App Engine.
And again, it has built in
redundancy so that you
automatically get replication
in order to work from a
variety of languages
and data centers.
Cloud SQL is a cloud hosted
version of MySQL, put simply.
If you're familiar with MySQL,
this is a version of MySQL
except where we do all
the management and
configuration for you.
It is available in both European
and US data centers,
depending on your preference.
It has very easy migration and
data portability, because
again, it is a version
of MySQL.
It's just one where we're
doing all the
management for you.
Between Cloud SQL and Datastore,
you really have a
choice depending on what your
application is using.
There's really no one
size fit all.
Sometimes I get asked, well,
should I use Cloud SQL or
should I like Datastore?
It really depends on
what you're doing.
Datastore is--
like I said-- a NoSQL, and
it's designed around very
large scale applications.
Cloud SQL is a more traditional
environment
designed to leverage all
the existing tools and
infrastructure that you're
familiar with.
So depending on both your
application type and your
data, one may be better
or worse or a better
choice than the other.
Let me go and talk about App
Services a little bit, which
is the third major category.
BigQuery is a set of
technologies--
it's a fully managed,
big data analytics .
Service what that means is
BigQuery allows you to upload
your data in whatever form you
have, and allows you to do
SQL-like analytical queries on
it without having to configure
data cubes or ETL or any of the
things that make querying
big data so difficult.
And again, if you think about
where this comes from, one of
the problems we faced early
on at Google was
analyzing log files.
Right?
Why did the Maps application
behave strangely for this user
or in this region?
Well, to do that, we actually
needed to be able to look
across the application
logs for Maps.
Across all these different
servers and users and
geographies.
And again, what were
we going to do?
Build a data cube and take all
of the logs globally from the
Maps application?
I don't think so.
So we developed a technology
that's the basis of BigQuery
that allows us to queries in a
SQL-like language against all
these different data stores.
That means that you can again
query terabytes of data using
a SQL-like interface.
A great use for this case is
just what we use it for--
application logging.
You can upload the log files of
your application and then
your business analysts can
quickly do queries to find out
which users are using which
features, or which users are
experiencing what
kind of errors.
Basically any sort of
data that you have
stored your log files.
Cloud Endpoints is a service
that's designed for a mobile
app [AUDIO DROP].
How many of you are building
mobile applications?
Yes.
And the rest of you that aren't,
you probably will at
some point.
One of the challenges you face
as a mobile developer is
connecting up your mobile
application to your back end
data logic.
Because mobile applications--
even games--
don't consist of just
client side code.
Their client side code plus
server side code that does
things like high score
processing, or rankings, or
selecting a player for
you to play against.
Cloud Endpoints is a technology
that allows you to
very easily connect up your back
end code to your clients.
You can go into App Engine, you
can pick a component of
App Engine.
With one click, you can create
a Cloud Endpoint.
And what that does, is it
creates a [INAUDIBLE]
REST interface, and it creates
the client side library for
iOS and Android that allows you
to just make a call on the
client and invoke code
on the server.
You don't have to worry about
data marshalling, you don't
have to worry about OAuth or any
of that hassles associated
with connecting up your
client side code to
your server side code.
Cloud Endpoints is really
designed on allowing you to
focus on the part of the
application that you care
about and not about
[? blue ?] code.
So who's using this?
One of the things we hear a
lot is gee, that sounds
interesting, but I don't
want to be the
first one do anything.
I want to know that there's
somebody else out there who's
actually being successful
with it.
Let me give you a couple
examples of some customers who
are actually using
this technology.
First of all, we currently
have about three million
active applications on a monthly
basis running on top
of the Google Cloud Platform.
So it represents everything from
small applications up to
very large applications that
companies are betting their
whole business on.
First one is Snap Chat.
I don't know if you guys
are aware of Snap Chat.
It's an incredibly popular
photo sharing
application for iOS.
It allows you to take a picture,
send it to somebody,
and then they can see the
picture and then after some
period of time, the picture
expires and is deleted.
They're currently delivering
about 150
million photos a day.
All running through the Google
Cloud Platform, both on the
storage side and the
compute side.
Song Pop is a game
that allows--
it plays a song, and then you
have to compete to who can
identify what the song
is the fastest.
They currently serve about 18
terabytes of media a day
coming out of the
Cloud Platform.
And they have about 80 million
users on a daily basis
accessing Song Pop.
How many have heard
of Eurovision?
Everybody, right?
Eurovision, this year-- they
were faced with the problem of
their online voting system.
They knew that they were going
to have a big traffic spike.
They knew it was going to come
in a short period of time.
And they knew that when
it was done, they
didn't need the capacity.
So Eurovision came to us and
said would you help us build
out this infrastructure?
They used Compute Engine, and at
its peak, they were serving
50,000 requests per second
as people we're
logging on to vote.
90% of those requests were
served in less than 24
milliseconds response time.
That was all built on
Compute Engine.
They were able to scale
up, meet the needs.
Now that it's scaled down, their
bill has gone back down
to nearly zero.
Scalar is a US company that
does cloud management.
And, in fact, they've done a
number of benchmarks of VM
start up time, VM performance,
network performance, disk
performance.
If you're interested in a really
good benchmarking of
how we compare with other VM
cloud based environments,
they're a great place to look.
They're the ones who've really
done a lot of really good work
to put our performance
in context
with other cloud platforms.
I definitely recommend you
take a look at them.
Udacity is an online educational
software.
And what I like about them is I
loved the quote that I have
here from their software
engineer.
Which gets at the point I've
been talking about.
"I'd rather be democratizing
education than scaling
memcache [? D." ?]
And I think that's the essence
of what we're trying to do
here with the Cloud Platform.
You've got some great
idea for an
application you want to build.
We want to let you spend your
waking hours building that
application, not mucking about
with a bunch of frankly boring
infrastructure that somebody
else can provide for you.
Pulse is an online news reading
application that
allows you to read RSS
another news feeds.
Talk about that hyper growth
model we talked about.
In 18 months their user
base went up 70 times.
Without the Cloud Platform,
there's just simply no way
they would've been able
to maintain that.
Their users would have had
experience, and frankly their
business would have just
crashed and burned.
Last thing I want to talk
about-- just raw
performance with MapR.
There's a benchmark out there
called MinuteSort.
And what MinuteSort does is it
basically says how many random
numbers can you sort
in one minute.
The world record for that
was just broken on
top of Compute Engine.
And what I find fascinating
about it is not just that it
was able to sort one and 1/2
terabytes of random numbers in
60 seconds using 8,000 cores,
but that the previous
benchmark was done on
custom hardware.
And I believe cost on the
order of about a million
dollars-- the hardware.
This version was done on a
publicly available cloud
platform with Compute
Engine for--
I'll have to look
up the number--
I believe it's on the order of
a couple thousand dollars.
So it's a radical difference
in the price performance.
And it really demonstrates one
of the core values we've
placed on Compute Engine, which
is very high performance
and very high consistency
of performance.
So with that, I want a
transition over to Peter who's
going to talk in detail
about App Engine.
If I leave it with one thing
about the Cloud Platform, it's
that we are investing in
fundamental infrastructure at
Google because we need to.
Because we're building out
things like Search and Maps.
And with Cloud Platform we're
really opening up that same
infrastructure that we are using
ourselves for you to run
your applications on.
This is the beginning
of a process.
You can expect over the next
year we're going to have more
features, more performance, as
we continue to invest more and
more of this.
And I'd love to talk to you
during the Q&A or during the
break to find out more about
what you're doing and how our
Cloud Platform could be the
basis for your next great
application.
So with that, I think Peter is
next to give you a drill down
on App Engine.